one of the main lessons rick rubin
taught me when we worked with him on
this record was he would say
he would his his
main point that he would continually
bring up when like
because he he's not the type person be
like that's a bad song or that's good
it's just not who rick rubin is it's
more like there's more nuance to it he
would say
i don't really believe you on that song
that's what he would say he would say
and i knew that was like
that song's a no-go you say and i and i
would genuine there was a time you said
it and it was about a song that i really
like i really
felt it and meant it when i said it
but
he didn't believe it when he heard it
and that was enough i was like man well
at the end of the day like i can believe
it all i want but if the listener
doesn't feel the honesty in it just like
we were talking about earlier i think
the most important ingredient is is this
truth perceived as truth
to someone else and if it's not the
[ __ ] indicator goes and you're like
i don't care i don't throw it away i
don't care about it well he you said
that he made you go through
like line by line the lyrics every
example that was excruciating for me
why was that excruciating well first of
all it's rick rubin so you're in the
room with like rick rubin who's done a
lot of the greatest
of all time
and um
so i had to first just put that aside
and be like okay well you've done a lot
of my favorite records but still you're
you're human and not everything you say
is gonna be right you know i and i'm a
strongly opinionated person and so is
rick and so when the two of us were kind
of together it was
you know
um but the lyrics which is interesting
so it's not every entire composition but
just like let's look at the lyrics yeah
i mean here yeah oh yeah because he
would look over every there was like um
[Music]
and there was there were battles he won
battles that that he didn't win and
maybe he was right i don't know i mean
there was for instance i'll give you an
example there's a song on the record
called number one okay rick will
probably laugh when he hears this
um
because this was a big one that we kept
going back and forth on but this will
give you a good insight of what it's
what it was like what it was like and
there's a line in it that says um
i don't know the course is i don't know
what i meant to be i don't need no one
to believe when it's all been said and
done i'm still my number one and he was
like nah just makes me cringe when i
hear that
he's like i just like do you have to be
like can it not be like you're still my
number one i was like no it's not about
anybody else like you know it's about
like self-love he's like yeah but like
do you need to like talk about self-love
like that and i was like well i can't i
feel like i need to it's like oh but you
know there's something else we could say
there like we just kept
you know we kept coming back to this
song okay i was like i and i changed it
i tried changing it like what did i
change it to it was like it wasn't
you're still my number one because it
just made no sense it wasn't about some
love thing or like someone else
i changed to something else and it just
it was the one thing that i was like i'm
really sorry rick like
i get it
and if it sounds cringy to you it's
definitely sounding cringy to other
people too and that sucks but
i don't know how else to say this in a
way that i want to put that song out
anymore
but there were other songs for sure
where rick was like that or this that
word
feels a little trite you already said
that once can you say it in a different
way that was really helpful and that
yeah it's really interesting because uh
you're trying to say something so simply
and yet not make it cringe
that's really hard that's that's like a
that's a strange art form because you
want to say some of the greatest love
songs we i mean we looked at the the
without you song i mean that's the whole
thing is cringy if you just read it on
paper like i said
like like it's a court report or
something but
yet it's not especially when sung maybe
but no there's something about
yeah
maybe
sung in a way you believe it when you
believe it but also written in a way
that's
singable in the way you believe it so
it's like
right and then it rolls off it just
comes out in a way that just feels like
silky and no word catches your mind as
cringy yes
just
uh but then music
um i think great speeches are like that
too or just
you know conveying communicating ideas
simply
that's the that's the art form is to not
be cringy so interesting and then yet
because like when you're raw and real
it might at first feel cringy
so the the battle there and that that's
where
you see people fail like just regular
artists like um i don't know open at
open mic i go to open mic so i just
listen
to musicians like when they write songs
like they they fail that test
they write simple stuff but it's cringey
why i wonder what was that like what is
that i'm telling you like i tried to
explain this to my brother the other day
because it's the same thing with a live
performance if i'm not in my right head
space and i walk on stage and i walk up
and let's say i say something and i do
this
yeah hey cause i'm like this is the move
right i'm like this is the move
the crowd doesn't care yeah in fact the
crowd is like that's cringy when you did
yes but if i wasn't thinking about doing
this and i went up there and i said
something i really meant it and my body
was like
i can't explain this to you and it's so
silly to say out loud but it's
people will resonate to it when it's
real and when it's acted it doesn't you
could do it the exact it could the
motion could look the same your eyes
look the same but there's something
about the energy
that people know they know if it's real
or not yeah people are like you said
incredible [ __ ] detectives 100 i'll
go on a stage and if i'm not in the
right headspace to be real it won't be a
good show if i'm real then it's a good
show it's simple as that
you